yeah stand up it's [ __ ] hard in that
way you know but um but once you figure
it out you know it's good yeah once you
start putting pieces together like it
starts to fit like a narrative which is
fun start to talk about what happened in
your day like one of the tricks I do now
and I too like long sets is that I in
the beginning I try to improvise you
know that that way I hold my materia as
long as possible that's I do that too
really I I did you know what sometimes I
do I go I want to see how long can go
without saying it without seeing a joke
and see how long sometimes you can last
five minutes yeah sometimes ten seconds
right to material and then you go right
into material it's really weird
well you were there the first time he
did stand-up oh yeah I blacked out too
that's when I improvised you know what's
so impressive you were supposed to like
eight minutes really of doing like I was
this very first time cuz he before
someone forced him out there yeah I
remember bro you decimated talk about
being scared to go up after I was scared
to go up after you it was in Brea oh
yeah I was like oh boy like what do I do
now but bro you decimated the room it
was something had act how's my act out
voice it was so nervous to I was like
he's gonna eat it he's gonna eat it so
watch old Bobby Lee YouTube videos you
know what dude likes it's I mean I you
can do what you want but that's the key
to you I cannot believe you didn't keep
up with Stan yeah I don't know why you
don't know anyway it's so Dom you don't
tell you what happened after that I
decided I came with all that hot
confidence I decided to hit the open
mikes for a week yeah and that whew that
just like I destroyed that made me go oh
I'm not funny I need to learn how to
write jokes and not they about charisma
yeah but yeah yeah but how are you funny
how can you be funny in front of just a
bunch of comics and no audience at 2:00
in the morning that the the open mic
scene isn't about you getting laughs
it's about going through boot camp right
it's that yeah your your training right
it's not about you know you can go in
front of a crowd and kill yeah but
that's not what that's there for that's
for paying your
DUS on all that other stuff if you're
not willing to do that then don't do it
but my point is is that I really believe
that you're missing out on a gigantic
opportunity talk non-pom yeah you know
when Bobby said earlier is like on The
Tonight on The Late Late Show is like if
you're bobbing act like you're doing
well that's something you learn on at an
open mic no one's laughing comics are
just waiting to go up so you're just
like and you know set a punch instead of
punch and then you get off you're like
[ __ ] me but it's an exercising
worst-case scenario if you say that joke
and no one laughs can you still go on to
the next one and not get off in 60
minutes or go back and behind the stage
and look at my list
like I saw Rogen once like years ago 15
years ago when I first moved to LA it
was a rowdy show no or whatever and
people were just talking and whatnot and
he did something interesting he started
pulling back his vocals to the point
where he was almost whispering he was
still talking in a normal voice and then
the room quieted down just to hear them
you know matey they wanted to hear him
you know that your gut instinct is to
like talk over them that makes it worse
a lot of times you if you just pull back
but you learn all those little tricks
from just doing it you know but also
just in terms of opportunity if I didn't
have stand-up I wouldn't be in the
position I'm in right now I wouldn't
have anything I'm not strong enough as a
as a comedic actor you know everything
that I get is through my reputation and
all the things I've done and what I
bring to it but all that is based on the
route was just calm stand up I mean they
put my name up at The Comedy Store every
night for the last 20 years that just
subliminally you know people try by that
you know it's it's it's all a part of I
just think that I would not make it if I
didn't have it it's like having the
muscle but not using it for anything
you have the muscle it's there and then
you're just letting it atrophy for no
good
reason why not flex it you know yeah but
also I want you to feel the pain okay
George is laughing because he goes to
open mics everyday oh I want you to feel
the pain of like years of like nothing
happening already feel you know I'm
ready feeling it and I want you to go
okay I have to try everything yes I
still hit up open mics all the time I
mean I can't tell you how many like you
can do two or three like on Wednesday
this one did if you're not doing
anything you know there's a run that you
can do three open mics within like 50
yards of one another you saw that sounds
comedy hole you go to donkeys Art
Gallery and then you do the coffee shop
right next door all within you know
walking distance so if you want to do it
look you know let's do it on Wednesday I
do it all the time when it also here's
another thing when I first came to LA
the 97 Hollywood Boulevard was dangerous
it wasn't it what it was it was
prostitutes there there were drugs I
mean it was not what it is now they
didn't have the [ __ ] cadmium wards
they didn't have that what adjust with
that whatever that [ __ ] theater they
have the Academy Awards didn't have any
of that
it was [ __ ] a disaster so there was
this [ __ ] alleyway where there was
this like [ __ ] Club they did open mic
and I remember going there all every
week and there was no one in the
audience and it was dingy remind you in
the movie se7en it was just like oh he's
just kind of dark and you're gonna find
a [ __ ] dead body or something and I
remember meeting this guy there he was
this fat redheaded kid that did open
mics with me and he he wore a white
shirt and wore a gigantic green tie that
was like thick right and he would go up
and just scream at people what he's now
an executive at Comedy Central Jordy
yeah but back then
Jordy and I and let me say this like
every like all that you like you know
every job I get from Comedy Central is
all through Jordi Jordi will just text
me do you want to do this
but that relationship is only there
because we went to boot camp together
and forged it there
yeah and that's that's why that's also
important you know is is that you meet
even guys that like I don't hang out
with that ice like you know when I see
like when I saw Zack after nakos at that
movie I did that keeping up with the
Joneses he was there and I remember him
looking at and seen him in years since
hangover I hadn't seen him see blue Bob
early mmm and he looked at me and he
gave me like a like a war buddy a war
buddy hug like hey there we you know you
weren't there man no I mean like it was
that kind of like trenches yeah and he
treated me so night like we were
brothers and I think I equated to just
going growing up with these guys you
know you're missing out on that too
but you know what you did do sketch you
are from you know you do live shows and
that's a part of it too and that's great
but I just I you can do it you know I've
seen you do it you're so unbelievably
amazing for me a little amount of time
that you did do it but you're you live
in fear and a little bit of delusion oh
god oh god okay you do
[Music]